This one means that we're first summing up all the values, and then we're taking
the absolute value. Since these are all positive, taking the absolute value
won't do anything. It'll already be positive, but this says nothing about the
deviations. In fact, this will just be the mean again. This one says that you're
finding the absolute deviation. So you're taking a value minus the mean, which
are these deviations. But then taking the absolute value of them, here, adding
them all up, with this sigma, and then dividing by n, the total number. Which in
this case is 10. So this one does describe what you did. This one says that
you're finding each deviation, which are here. You're taking the absolute value,
which are here. You're dividing each of these by n, which in this case is ten.
And then you're adding all of them up, which will give you the same thing as if
you first added all of these up, and then divided by 10. So this one also
describes what you did. This one, looks like it's going the opposite direction,
so instead we're taking the mean and then subtracting each of these values. So
we would get the opposite of each of these. We would get positive 19,574. This
would also be positive, but these would be negative. But then it says we take
the absolute value, which will lead us right back to this column here. Because
it doesn't matter if these are negative or positive. Then we divide by n, and we
get the same thing as this. This one says that we're just using one data value.
We don't know which one it is, so tracking the mean, taking the absolute value,
and then dividing by n, which doesn't give us what we want. This was very
tricky, but the more you work with formulas, the more comfortable you'll get
with them. And don't worry, by the end of this course, you're really going to
understand all of these symbols and formulas that we're using. And it'll really
help you in expressing mathematical ideas.